This is Radiolab. I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich.
Today our topic is liars and the people who try and catch them.
And we've got a tale for you now from our own Ellen horn.
The story that she heard from a friend of hers, Robert, which? No. Uh, so Jude,
your friend Jude. Yup. What a t describe him real quick for us. Shoot.
So a sweet guy. We used to work together. He keys,
kind of a slight fellow with Auburn hair and he's just a really thoughtful,
trustworthy guy. How do you know?
What do you mean? How do you know that he's trustworthy? Well, you just know.
I don't know. Huh? Okay. Tell me about the story that you told you.
Well, this is a story about someone that he dated and someone who changed him.
It's the girl that's a girl and how many meter he met her at a barbecue,
a friend's party. And incidentally it was my birthday, right?
He was at this party. It was his birthday. He meets this girl,
sandy blonde hair, blue eyes. And after the party a couple days later,
he gets a phone call from his friend saying,
do you remember hope who was at at the party on Sunday?
She was asking after you, okay, is it okay if I give her your phone number?
Tell her how to get in touch with you. Are you flattered? Of course.
So she calls, he asked her out and they went out on a date.
I remember thinking to myself, wow, this girl is, she's kind of electric,
vibrant. We're saying yes a lot to each other.
We're laughing a lot. Yeah. She just had a wonderful smile.
She would look you right in any,
I mean she just had a way of connecting right through to the back behind your
own eyes. Okay.
You just felt like you were dealing with,
so they went on again and then they went out again and pretty soon the shipping
all
their time together. And then what happened? Well,
I don't remember when it turned.
At some point she started to have a lot of problems.
Small crises started to come up, a whole series of things.
They were [inaudible] problems, insurance problems. You know,
I've got a situation where I need to move out of the place where I'm currently
living and it's because my roommates, you know, crazy.
He's felt himself sort of pulling back. Yes, yes.
Until one evening he gets a call from hope and she's totally panicked so you
have to come over, we have something we really need to talk about.
And at this point I haven't, I have no idea what it is, but now at this time,
but uh, she said, hey, I'm pregnant.
I think I'm pregnant. Wow. But what did you do? Well,
he basically stood up and did the right thing. I think
there really was a part of me that was thinking, well,
here's the test of a person who is going to stand by her and support her through
the pregnancy. And he said, okay, let's go to the doctor together. I would say,
where when I want to be there and she would say three o'clock at the doctor's
office. Then I would say, okay. And I would go be there early, you know,
two 45 and uh,
she would not be there at three 15 would roll around and three 30 roll around
there I am sitting sort of alone and the receptionist would sort of continue,
continue, you know, can I help you? She would say,
oh well that that appointment was at one o'clock or I would notice on the sign
in sheet that she had actually signed in and I could see the handwriting.
It was indeed, it was hopes and she had signed it two hours earlier.
So then did you confront hope about giving you the wrong appointment time? Yeah.
Oh yeah. Yeah. And as this continued, I would say, repeat that for me. Three.
Okay. So three o'clock. I mean, these are moments in crystal clarity of life.
You're not losing track of stuff.
Then he gets a call from a woman named Leslie. I met hope off craigslist,
actually put out an ad for a roommate and she moved in with no furniture.
She showed up with just all of her stuff in trash bags and then she disappeared
leaving the bags behind.
So it was right around that point where her check bounced and I was like, oh no.
And so through a mutual friend, she tracked down Jude. I, it was kind of like,
okay, well she has this boyfriend, she called him,
called him and sort of wondered like,
is he in on this dude had no idea what she's talking about. No,
he didn't even know she had a roommate named Leslie. I mean, who the hell was,
who are, you know, who are you? You owe me money and no I don't. And she,
you know, it was all very confusing not knowing what else to do.
Leslie decides to go into hope's room and start looking through her style and I
just thought, you know, I'm just going to go through this.
Let's see what's in here. And that's when I found those notebooks.
[inaudible]
spiral-bound notebooks and inside literally pages upon pages of different names
with different socials next to them. Credit card numbers, mother's maiden name,
birth date, page after page of that kind of information.
What exactly was this? These are like crib notes for con woman.
That's when I called Jude and I said, get over here.
What did you do at this point? Well, Jude knew he had [inaudible]
and I finally got up the courage to confront pope and say,
this is over my own responsibility here. Not withstanding to the, um, you know,
the pregnancies. Well, and what about Leslie at this point? Was she,
well,
Leslie wondered how many of those people in that notebook hope had met through
craigslist, which is where Leslie met her.
So she went back to craigslist and started posting warnings many times a day.
Thanks. Single white female makes Pacific Heights, meets the grifters,
be like 20 something gap closed, five foot three blue eyed blonde runaway,
runaway. In fact, war on your hairdresser. She's posting. Warning after warning.
If you have any information about this person or simply want some empathy,
please
email@khanbyhopeatyahoo.com and Craig took them all down as in Craig from
craigslist. Craig Newmark, Alger of craigslist.
He thought that they were inappropriate, they were unfair,
but do the right thing. But everyone has rights.
She would pose note the drama is not okay. He would take it down.
She would post back to the matters that hope is out there somewhere.
He would take it down,
but within a few days in those moments where Craig was in the bathroom away from
his desk, people respond to other stores and they get multiple reports at.
She ripped off every
different kind of person from all over the place. Yoga instructors,
landlord's car mechanic, spanks, flower shop owners, boss, veterinarian,
Car Rental Agency, check cashing place,
$50 $500 1000 proximally,
$10,000 and everybody with the same story.
She one good act for emo seems to be to move in with tons of stuff.
Sands furniture will pass the check out of a closed account than bolt when it
comes back. Over the course of several years,
there were posting Tom Hertz list and there were people who were trying to find
and stuff. Oh, she got kind of a celebrity following.
By the way. We used to get emails like every day from people who were just like,
is there any news dude, I love seeing those posts. Can you tell us anything?
I'm like, no, she's in hiding. Sorry.
Who was this woman? I'm teary. Can I get you to introduce yourself?
Just say who you are and what you [inaudible].
My name is Terry Allario.
I'm a special agent with the Louisiana Department of Justice
Louisiana. Yeah. How'd we get to Louisiana? Well, after a few years,
hope resurfaced in New Orleans,
we had a call in complaint from a lady down in the New Orleans area.
Her credit card had been used.
Someone had tried to purchase Dell computers and it just started from there.
Every time we talked to one victim had led to one or two other victims. Got It.
Hope has a almost like a cult following, you know,
her emo was that she knew him. She got to know him really well.
I talked a lot of victims and they just don't trust people anymore.
A lot of these people did some good human open-heart things with her and said,
this poor girl, I've got to help her out, and they were,
they were really let down and you just don't trust people anymore and it's sad,
you know?
Not only do you have to worry about clearing up your credit and getting your
money back from your banks, you know you've got to deal with,
with people on the surf now and that you don't know, you know,
who you're standing next to.
She had had that feeling for good reason and one of the houses that hope it
blown through in San Francisco,
he had found something that was really upsetting.
I had come across it a letter that she had written to my parents but never
mailed, just sings very, very terrible things,
which Jude says were totally untrue in this letter to his parents.
Hope wrote
at at one point during pregnancy
she was having complications and the main symptom was like severe vaginal
bleeding and that this, that she was on somebody's living room floor,
other minor, hers in this terrible condition and that,
um, that I had that I just left totally abandoning the situation and my
responsibilities.
Just a graphic and ugly depiction of an awful scene.
She was traumatized. The whole experience. He compared to an earthquake
five year ago, urban
been an earthquake? No, never. Well, one the things that happens
is that there's these aftershocks after the earthquake and so for a little while
after the earthquake, you're not sure that when you put your foot down,
the ground is still going to be in the same place as it was a minute ago.
There were days,
I can tell you there were days when it was significant to hear anybody say
anything of any consequence. That was just true.
You know, to say,
I have a carton of milk in my refrigerator that expires on September 17th and
that was true.
It didn't say September 19th or September 15th it said September 17th I've had
people crying on the phone talking to me about this situation and they were
victim six, seven years ago. People are embarrassed, they're embarrassed,
and then they become [inaudible]
mad, you know? And that's when they become detective,
make a lousy private attack.
Where are you now in front of hope's mother's house in a bad neighborhood in New
Orleans. Then around midnight. What's her name, by the way? Her mom. Oh,
Marsha Ballantine. And why are you there? Exactly. Ah, you could,
could kind of gotten a little obsessed with him. You got obsessed. Yeah.
I can't see any else. Number six to me why?
I have no idea.
I said this having tightness in my chest. I'm feeling nervous.
There was something about imagining how she was doing all this and so nervous.
It was like really fun to imagine and maybe that's what happens to Leslie to
that. Like once I started looking, I was able to find a lot of victims,
a lot of information, and I wanted to meet her.
Marsha Ballantine. Marsha Ballantine. Yeah.
I'm not from around here.
I'll come back later. Okay, next day. All right. We hold up.
But what did you know about hope at this point? Well,
I knew that she had had a daughter who really knows anybody. Home
Jews? No, not Jude's. The timing was all wrong.
And I had located the father well and standing outside of hope's mother's house,
there's three classic tricycles piled up against a gate.
I don't see anyone inside the house.
The next morning I went out to find a woman named Ruby Ruby Moon.
I live in New Orleans, Louisiana. Ruby owns a coffee shop.
I lived down the street from hope's mother then when hope came to New Orleans,
um, her mother, you know, introduced us.
Ruby has a kid who's about the same age as hope's daughter and they go to
Montessori together. And when Ruby opened her shop a year ago,
hope did Carpool duty, she would pick them up.
And when we got home about five 30, six o'clock,
we'd all eat dinner together and she would spend the night sometimes.
And quite frankly, I enjoyed having hope. Around a few weeks later,
the cops show up to arrest.
Hope she had printed a check on her home with a made up account number two by
$12,000 used car. Here you are. You really like this woman.
Your kids love her and you can't believe it. You don't believe it.
And I wanted to stand by her. I wanted to help her, you know,
and she hadn't screwed me over. She hadn't done anything to me.
So maybe she's turning around.
Well.
Then my husband finds that she's taken a credit card off of the shelf that he
put away because the credit card was maxed out and she had been buying gasoline
and paying her phone bill wasn't much. It was like $250 it really wasn't much,
and my husband was like, hope. Why?
Why didn't you just come to us? Here you are. You're living in a house.
You are nanny, you're a friend. We would've given you the money.
And here's where Ruby's situation is so different from the other victims I
talked to. She loves hope's daughter.
She can't just walk away when hope went to jail for four months,
ruby helped care for her. It's a very, very difficult situation,
especially when you're trying to do the right thing,
trying to do the right thing.
Ruby hired hope's mom to work at her coffee shop even though she's kind of pin
it off a waitress. I mean,
she's worked here for three months and she still forgets how to do things.
I mean, I don't know, but here's the thing, the a lie, like the real impact.
It isn't just that it makes you question that piece of information that you were
lied to about. It said it makes you question everything.
What happened next was that I watched ruby completely unravel because of
something that I said. Do you understand that hope's father was a doctor,
which the detective had told me her father was a doctor.
My understanding was that he wasn't really adopted Derek
according to the Attorney General's office.
Then Marsha's not a liar too
cause she says he was a con man. She says that Hubspot is his apartment.
It's funny how a piece of information can take on a life of its own.
The ground was shifting, staying under Ruby's feet. So then marsh is lying.
Marsha says he wasn't a doctor.
If they say it turned out that he was really a doctor there, the Marshall's line
and I had it.
I mean that that may not be information that needs anything at all and now
you're telling me that he really was a doctor.
I should be getting call after call. Hey baby, it's ruby. They handle lady.
Can you give me some information? She found it.
Anyone she knew what the connection to home.
Can I ask you a question and you just say yes or no. Hi Scott, this is ruby.
I live in New Orleans. Um, you don't know me.
I heard some disturbing news that I would like to do. Very,
very important that you call me back my number. Please call me back.
Hey, I'm freaking out. It's her talking to her husband. Well,
I'm sitting here talking to the reporter and, and
through things that has told me aren't true,
that hope's dad wasn't really a doctor and he was,
and I still really don't understand why that one detail shook ruby so much.
I guess betrayal makes you doubt yourself,
but it explains something that you had told me that he has no new friends
literally,
that everyone he feels close to is someone that he met before he met hope as if
he never trusted his judgment about people again,
but that he had no choice but to rely on it from before. I mean,
how could you live in the world without trusting?
What sort of world would that be?
So, um, I am in front of the Jefferson parish courthouse.
Hope has a trial this morning.
40th been here since eight this morning and I haven't as yet seen home.
I have been trying [inaudible]
to reach her for a week and a half. Left her phone messages,
mailed her a letter, left her right
note at the drawer. Nothing constraint. I feel like she's not coming.
Okay. Inside the courtroom.
I am watching the door at every person who walks in wondering is it her,
is it her? And then she walks in, she walked in and she's,
had you ever seen her before this moment? Pictures of her.
What did she look like? What did she look like? Well,
strawberry blonde hair, blue pinstriped suit and pointy toed high heels.
She sort of looks like an attorney, very well put together.
And I watch her look around this court room at all of the intimidating and scary
looking people in the court.
And I see her see me and she just makes a beeline right for me and walks up to
me and says, you're Ellen, aren't you? You've been trying to reach me.
And I'm so sorry I haven't been in touch and she just sits down next to me and
we ended up spending the next four hours together.
And what'd you talk about the weather mostly. She was very charming.
She told me all sorts of things about New Orleans, New Orleans history,
and when it comes time for her to stand before the judge and plead guilty,
I find myself rooting for her. She gets sentenced to two years on hard labor,
but she also gets a couple of days to make arrangements for her daughter.
She has to report to prison at 9:00 AM on Friday morning.
Do you ever get her on the record? Well,
I couldn't have my equipment in the courtroom, but while while we were in court,
she agreed to an interview. Okay.
But then a few hours before the scheduled interview,
she called me and told me she couldn't make it move to the next morning.
Then the next day and the next,
and while I know I can't trust her, I don't know what else to do.
I decided to run to the drugstore and buy a tape recorder and bring it to her.
So I go to her mom's house.
Yeah, definitely. Hey there. Huh?
At least it's a little bit better weather for your white dress. Yeah, totally.
It's freezing yesterday. Hey there. It's my mother. Hi, I'm Ellen. Hi Ellen.
How are you cleaning up dog.
Hi Bear. Well, you didn't call her by her name.
What's her? Ellen?
So I'm trying to make it really UV.
There's set recorder. It's got batteries. It's got a cassette in it.
I tested it out. It works. Okay. And um,
yeah, you gotta put batteries in your bubble thing too. I know. Um,
and my other thought is as if you want to just record your thoughts and what I
mean, you know,
like I just want to write you some space to say what you want to say. So,
um, okay. And it's all addressed,
posted solid dress to seal it up. And um,
yeah, I'm sorry. Okay. I can give you better.
Well, is though,
that was it. That was my only on the record interview with her. However,
before she went to prison, she did send me that cassette tape.
It was a really crummy tape and so we had to use this voice out. What are you,
what do we call that noise reduction and you use a noise reduction filter to
clean it up so you could hear her voice and it makes her sound kind of
ghostliness.
It's strange. I have a child have a
beautiful, and I don't think she could be all about it.
I was this horrible months or [inaudible] on this tape hook talks about her
daughter a lot. My life. Yes ma'am. All right.
I wish you said something more satisfying.
Something that explained why it was that she chose to live this way for so long,
but she doesn't, I'm sorry.
Hope Man. This tape to me reported to prison.
She was released due to prison overcrowding and during Hurricane Katrina,
the state of Louisiana lost her.
About a month after the hurricane I wrote to the Attorney General's office and
asked if they had any idea where she was. I got a one word response.
No
radio labs. Ellen Horn. All right,
so let me ask a question to get us to our next, next bit. [inaudible] why? Why,
why exactly would hope lie the way she does? I mean,
there was a point in the story where, where I'm ruby you,
one of the characters said, you know,
I would have given her everything she wanted. I would've given her the money,
credit cards, whatever, and yet she still did it.
So why haven't you met people who lie all the time like this?
Just keep doing it and doing it and things like they, it's like they can't stop,
right? Yeah, exactly. They just can't help it.
They feel this impulse that they cannot control. Yeah.
The light just tumbles out before they can stand. That is who, oh,
that's yelling yacht.
She's a researcher at the University of Southern California,
the Department of psychology and your science. And I'm a new mom,
not really new mom.
Her baby's about two months old and she was nice enough to let barge in on her
maternity leave to talk with her because when she's not playing with her new
baby, she is studying the mind of pathological liars.
Which by the way means what do you use that phrase? Pathological lying.
What is it? What does zero definition? I just, I just said it a moment ago.
It's people who can't stop lying. It's a visual. It's compulsive yearlings.
Question was, is there something about their brains,
their anatomy that might explain this compulsion and she thinks she may have
found a clue in any case, getting him myself.
First thing she had to do was find a group of people who lie a lot. Why? Oh,
to study them. To study them. Yeah.
How do you find sitting pathological liars waiting to be studied?
We actually recruit out subject from the temporary employment agency,
like a temp agency where you know you would go if you type 60 words a minute
kind of place. Yes, exactly. Exactly.
This is her notion that she's funded a bunch of liars at a 10 pages,
so ridiculous. It's not ridiculous heavy. Her idea was that the,
that liars would be over-represented at a temp agency. You can probably imagine,
you know people who need to go to the temp agency or usually people who cannot
remain in one job. For a very long period of time.
That's not true of all people who work at temp agencies,
most of them are just fine,
but some of them she figured keep ending up at the temp agency because they just
have this palm with their, you know, their lifestyle. The truth prop. All right,
let's keep going. I want to hear how this comes out and they get so yelling.
And her crew went to a couple of temp agencies in the La area,
interviewed 108 people as some all kinds of questions,
not just about their employment history, but about their past.
Their childhood history of their family's very personnel information,
checked their answers to those questions against their family and friends
against their court records,
just to see if she could find people who stories had do you know in
consistencies big ones. And in the 108 folks that she queried,
she found a pathological liar.
12 actually 1212 out of 108 samples. Whoa.
Are they pathological learners? I don't know. It depends on how you define it.
I would hope that she found 12 people that you wanted to look at further.
She said to them,
would you be willing to come in on a purely voluntary basis into the lab and let
me scan your brain
just another day at the temp office?
Basically it would put people in the MRI scanner and then we scan their brain,
scanned everyone's brains, all 108 participants, the liars and the Non Liars.
No one knew which group they were in and she was looking at a particular part of
their brains just behind their forehead called the prefrontal cortex.
This is the part of the brain that process,
the information is where the real thinking happens.
Decisions and more judgment. For example.
Now if you zoom into that place just behind your forehead,
what you'll see are two kinds of brain tissue.
You've got gray matter and then you've got white matter.
I've heard of great matters. Yes. Well, we think if the brain is being great,
but actually it's two things. It's great and white, the gray stuff,
and kind of think of it as like the computer processor part. Yeah.
It's these little clumps of neurons that process information
like computer chips. That's the great, where's the white white matter?
It's like the,
the connections between all these complete computer and the white matter.
In other words is what moves the thoughts around gray is where the thinking
happens. And then white is when you move the thought from here to there.
Exactly. Yes. They transfer information from one end to the other. Okay.
So you've got your gray, you've got your white.
What y'all link thought she would see when she looked into the brains of people
who lie a lot? I thought we would see a reduction.
Just some piece of it. Not there. Yeah. They're missing something differently.
She thought she would find less gray stuff. Less of the thinking stuff.
Why wouldn't, why would, why? Because that's what she's seen in other, um,
mental disorders that are kind of like this.
And if you think about it in a really simplistic level,
the gray is where you think your thoughts.
And it's also among other things where you crunch your moral calculations and
liars. She figured it out of trouble in this department.
So maybe they have less gray. That was her notion,
but when she got the pictures back,
what she saw was such a great increase in more and not the gray.
Why matter more white stuff.
A lot more like a quarter.
They have 25% more connections in their head. The non liars. Yes.
Before we get to what that means, what were you thinking when you saw this?
I was really bubbling. I thought this was,
this was something, something, something, something.
Here's her idea. So far. You Ready? Yes.
She thinks that these extra connections play a crucial role in a kind of in the
moment storytelling. That's essentially what lying is.
Coming up with a story on the fly and let me give you an example. Okay.
You're leaving work,
you're walking down the hall and you're on the elevator and an annoying but nice
coworker corners you, corners you in the elevator
asks you out. Um,
you know I haven't been to ask you made me want to go out with me on Friday to,
there you are. Questions dangling in the air.
For most of us right at that moment inside our head and our brains were
thinking, oh, show, test, so you're busy. So you're busy saying, I'm busy.
What do you visit with citizen teaching,
reaching out into the void,
trying to form a connection with some idea that can help you come up with some
excuse. I can say, you know, I can say,
all right,
really what you need to do at this moment is you've take a bunch of disparate
thoughts on different sides of your brain. Like I'm me tonight, teeth,
dentists, and connect them all together.
I'm having some late night dental work like that. Okay, okay.
We can all do it given enough time. But for the pathological liar,
she thinks that because they have so many more of these connections to begin
with,
they're faster.
My mom is visiting that night and meeting a friend for Sushi for morning into
circus, practical cloudbees, hockey practice, Yoga. I have to polish the silver.
I've got chemo. The more connections, sorry, beekeeping.
The faster the speed of the processing.
You can jump from one idea to another and you can come up with more, um,
random stories. She thinks that in the brains of most of us,
we have trouble making this connections. We have,
would you have trouble if I said to you like, come on, come on,
go out with me on Friday night. Would you not be able to come up with a wowser?
I would say um, yeah, they um, yeah,
I have to stop. I have to count straws to see a third, 13, nine struck county.
We always, we have about 316 straws so far. And uh, I'm only,
I'm only doing ones with, with um, with little red circles on them.
So that's 39. Sorry. Like, I don't know. I did, it just happened.
I just, there you go. See you've got, you've got extra white matter per head.
So she's saying this is
cause of line or an effective line? Well, she's not sure.
And this is a big debate,
which he can say is that children as they grow from age two to eight 10,
there is a big jump in their why matters.
Oh, and that's it.
Actually the same age that they give up the skill to lie
among other things to close. Let me just ask you,
given everything we've just talked about, how do you see
where this information with being a new mom? I mean, um,
is this your first kid? Yes. It's my first one. A boy or girl. A girl.
What's her name? Ad Zoe.
Doesn't it make you wonder a little bit about Zoe and what's what's going on
inside her head? Oh yes. I wonder about that all the times.
It's still too early to scan her brain,
but eventually I will do it. Are you serious? Yes.
This is a moral to this. Never. If you're a little baby,
have a social psychiatrist. As a mother, we went to the fair,
we read the interest thing. Anyway, if she does this,
maybe we'll know a little bit more about the nature and nurture of liars,
but until then, this is radio lab and we'll be back
in a moment. Like to scan your brand.